[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDEEP PARIKH: All right,
good morning, everybody.
My name is Sandeep Parikh.
I run our Retail Solutions
architecture practice
for a Google Cloud,
and this morning I
want to talk to you about
end-to-end collaborative data
workflows and what those look
like inside a Google Cloud
Platform.
So what we're going
to cover today,
first, I want to lay out a
pretty simple, straightforward
challenge for you.
And then we'll break it down
into the individual tasks
that we're going to have
this team work on and try
to work through.
And then, we'll map those tasks
to a set of steps, components,
and tools that you would want
to leverage inside of GCP
to actually accomplish
the initial challenge.
And then, we'll try
to put it all together
and give you a sense
of what that, again,
that end-to-end
workflow looks like.
And I'm hoping I'm going
to be able to show you
a little bit of a demo as well.
Now, unfortunately, it's
not going to be a live demo.
It turns out it takes
about six to eight hours
for the end-to-end
workflow, and I
didn't want to keep you
here for the whole day.
So we're just going--
I'll have to do it
Food Network style,
and I'll have everything
kind of prebaked already.
But we'll walk through
what the steps and the UI
looks like at every stage.
And then finally, I want
to close on what's next,
and then I'm going to try
to leave a few minutes
for questions at the end.
And worst case
scenario, just come
find me right outside
the hall, and I'm
happy to chat it up with you.
We've also got mics in
the aisles here as well.
So with that, what problem
are we trying to solve?
What does a data
team typically have
to try to solve on
a regular basis?
So we'll pick
everybody's favorite,
and say our challenge here is to
build a recommendation system.
Now, that
recommendation system is
something we hope to use inside
of a running web application.
So you can imagine a
Netflix-style challenge here,
where we've got a web
app, we've got folks
who are able to rate movies.
And what we want them to do is
be able to see recommendations
in line as they're browsing.
So what is a team made up of?
What is the typical audience?
What are the folks
that are trying
to put this thing together?
So we've got the typical
cast of characters--
data scientists, a data
engineer, a business analyst,
and an app developer.
Right?
And I think depending
on your organization,
those roles may be different.
There may be some
overlap among them,
but ultimately, these
are the four main team
pillars we typically see
in a lot of customers.
All right, so what are
the steps or the tasks
that these teams
have to work through?
So the first thing is often
fall to the date engineer,
and that's where
they've got to transform
the data they're given.
Right?
You could imagine a
DBA, or someone that's
kind of running SRE for a
database infrastructure,
they may just export
some of the source data
that they're going to use
to build this recommendation
system.
So the first step is taking that
export, taking that raw data,
and turning it into
something useful.
The next step falls to
the business analyst,
where they actually
have to develop
some kind of an
understanding of the data.
Right?
This may be things like just
early analytical queries,
something that gives
them a sense of what does
this data really look like.
We're not going to have the
data engineer figure that out.
It's really on
them to transform.
Then, it falls into
the business analysts
to understand what's
inside that data set.
Well then, we're going
to get to model building.
So the first step for
the data scientist
now is to prototype an approach.
And you can imagine at
every step of the process,
these folks are learning
from the previous steps.
So that data scientist may
collaborate with that business
analyst and get some
early indication
of some of the patterns that
are inside that data set.
And they may use that as their
prototyping their approach
to building this model,
but first they've
got to get that
prototyping done.
So they've got to
come up with some kind
of an approach they're
going to use to build
this machine learning model.
And then, they actually
have to physically build it.
Right?
They've got to build it,
train it, even on a small data
center or local
environment, but they've
got to do something to
actually create this model.
But then, once that model
is trained and ready to go,
how do they get it
out into production?
And that's where the data
engineer comes back into play,
because it's not only important
just to build the model
and know that it works.
We've also got to run
this thing at scale,
so it can support the
application downstream.
So that data engineer is
going to deploy that model
to production, and
then the last step
is going to be integrating
that prediction mechanism
with the applications.
All right, so let's start
with our first set of tasks.
How do we transform and
understand data inside of GCP?
So remember, it's
that first chunk
of that timeline with the
data engineer and the business
analyst.
So there's three main
steps that typically
fall into this bucket,
and I'm sure this is not
completely exhaustive.
There's typically a lot more
work that might go on here,
but these are three of the
biggest pillars that we often
run into.
So the first step
is really going
to be acquiring that data,
grabbing all that raw data,
and storing and in some kind
of object storage mechanism.
Something that's
nice and scalable
that we can access from a
number of different tools.
Then, we'll have to turn all of
those flat files into something
useful, put some
structure on that data.
Cleanse it, transform it,
turn it into something
where we can actually
run queries against it
and start learning
from the data set.
And after that
transformation is done,
we actually want
to put it somewhere
where we can access
it, so typically
inside of a large
scale data warehouse.
So this is day three of
Next, so you probably
can guess which tools I'm
going to show you here.
So for acquiring and storing
that data in object storage,
GCS, Google Cloud Storage,
is a great fit for that.
For transforming the flat
files and the structured data,
we actually have a
bunch of different tools
we can use here, but
I like using Dataprep.
Mostly because it's
a nice visual way
to sort of dig around and
understand sample data,
and we'll talk through
a little bit of that
as we get further in.
Then, the last piece is BigQuery
petabyte scale, analytical data
warehouse, a perfect
place for ad hoc queries.
Again, we're in understanding
and model-building phase.
So it's early on.
This doesn't have to serve any
kind of transactional traffic
or anything.
All we're focused on
doing is giving ourselves
access to query and
understand the data.
So if we dig into each one
of those just a little bit,
this is an example of
what GCS looks like.
It's just a nice bucket
folder-style approach,
where I've created a
bucket in this case.
And the data set
I'm using, as we're
working through this example,
is like the MovieLens data set.
So I grabbed the 20 million
rating MovieLens data
set, unzipped it, dropped all
the CSV's into Google Cloud
Storage.
So now, I've got the
raw data sitting here.
So the next step
is transformation.
That's where Dataprep comes in.
Now, as I mentioned, Dataprep
is a great data wrangling tool.
It lets you pull in from
Cloud Storage or BigQuery,
transform all the data you want
to transform against, and then
actually dump that data
back out into Cloud Storage
or into BigQuery.
So it gives you that
input and output option.
What's really cool
about Dataprep
is that, behind the scenes,
the transformations that you
define, the steps that you
take, the filters you run,
are actually packaged up
into an Apache Beam job,
and that Beam job is actually
pushed to the Dataflow service.
So the actual execution
mechanism here is actually
Cloud Dataflow
behind the scenes,
and now the inputs and
outputs here with Dataprep
are somewhat limited.
This doesn't cover the
breadth of the platform.
If you need a level deeper of
maybe transformations, or maybe
you want to get through
inputting from Cloud Datastore
and outputting to a Cloud
SQL or Cloud Spanner,
that's where you want
to incorporate Dataflow.
But for our use case,
Dataprep works perfectly well,
because our data is
living in Cloud Storage,
and we want to make sure it
lands in BigQuery eventually.
So this is an example
of the Dataprep UI,
and what you'll
see-- and I get I'll
go through this a little
bit more in-depth as we get
to the demo part-- but
what I want you to notice
is that we've got this
row and column setup.
This is a CSV that I imported,
and this is the cleanse kind
of ready-to-go output.
But what you'll see across the
top there, in those green bars,
are actually Dataprep
sampling the entire column
and showing me a distribution
of all possible values there.
And so that kind of tooling
makes the analysis process
much easier.
It helps me figure out
which of these data sets
do I want to worry
about, which are
these columns do I care about?
Which ones do I want to
potentially transform or join,
as I'm thinking about what
I'm going to give access
to my business analyst.
And so here's what
a flow looks like.
So in the example I'm
going to show you,
I have the MovieLens
20 million rating data
So I've got the movies data
set up at the upper left.
The next one is ratings.
The Links file includes like
the movie database link or ID
and the IMDB ID for the movie.
And then the last one, in the
very bottom there, is the tags,
and I didn't really worry
too much about tags.
But what you'll see
up here is that I've
taken the movies
portion of the data set,
and the first thing I did
was clean it up a little bit.
And so things like genres were
pipe separated text fields,
and I wanted to make
that JSON array.
So I was able to do
that inside there,
as well as do things
like extract the year out
of the title and make
that its own column.
Then, I was actually
able to join it
with other data sets inside
of this whole large group.
So I took the ratings,
and I actually
created an average
rating, so kind
of a little bit of a swoop
down to the bottom there.
But I was able to compute
the average ratings per movie
from that 20 million set and
then push those average ratings
and join them up
back with the movies.
And so the nice thing here
is that the movies data
set itself was actually
able to be enriched,
all done inside of this tool.
And so all of those little--
I know they are a
little bit hard to see--
but all those little arrows
that are pointing to the right,
at the end of every step,
those are actually the job.
That's the output component.
So that's where I
get to decide, where
do I want to put
this data out to?
Do I want to append it
to an existing table
inside of BigQuery or
replace the data set?
So you have a lot of
flexibility with Dataprep.
It gives you a lot of
transformational power
around individual
data sets and how
you might want to work with
them, join them, use them.
So once that's set of jobs
runs, all my data lands inside
of BigQuery, and here's just a
quick screenshot of what that
looks like inside a BigQuery.
So I've got my set of
options on the upper left,
and I've got my data sets
on the lower left there.
And then, we see a
little bit of information
about the actual
physical data set itself.
Screen shot's not very exciting.
I'll show you more when we
actually run some queries.
But here's a quick
screenshot of what
that looks like inside the
BigQuery UI, so you can see.
We can run standard SQL
queries against this data now.
So any SQL capabilities you
might have for your business
analyst, they're able to go
ahead and run ad hoc queries
immediately against
this data set.
So we're already making
a little bit of progress
through the work that we've
got to do to get to build
that recommendation system.
So if we want to
get a level deeper
on exploring and
understanding data,
I think SQL is a
really powerful tool,
but it's not the right tool for
every single person out there.
And there are an incredibly huge
number of business intelligence
tools out there that we want
to be able to plug into.
So the great thing
about BigQuery
is that it does support
things like Tableau and Looker
and our own Data Studio product.
So that you can build
things, like reports,
dashboards, build kind
of exploratory analyzes,
of the data that
you're looking at.
So it's another nice
way to think about, how
can I examine and
understand this data,
because that's really what
we're trying to get to.
We're trying to make
sure we can develop
a really intense, in-depth
understanding, if we're
trying to build a predictive
component on top of it.
All right, so we've finished
the first major set of tasks.
Right?
We acquired the data set,
and we've transformed it
into something useful.
We've got a bunch
of tools we can
use to really develop
an understanding,
but how do we make
the next leap?
How do we move into building
a machine learning model?
So that's where the
data scientist comes in.
If you remember, we
have two big tasks here.
One, we've got to
prototype the approach,
and the second is we actually
have to build the model itself.
So the components that you'll
need to accomplish those tasks
for a data scientist.
One, obviously, you're going to
need a pretty powerful machine
learning framework, something
that you can lean on heavily
to support this kind of work.
And then, you actually
need an environment
to physically prototype
the approach within.
So inside of GCP we have two
good options there for you.
TensorFlow, which is
a scalable, machine
learning library and
framework, and Cloud Datalab,
which you can just imagine as
Jupyter notebooks or IPython
notebooks as a service.
So let's dig in a little bit.
TensorFlow is
incredibly powerful.
It's also relatively
complicated,
and I'm a TensorFlow
newbie myself,
so this took me a little bit
of work to get all this up
and running.
But think of it as a
powerful open source
library for really
high performance
numerical computation.
The great thing
about TensorFlow is
I think it establishes
a really nice baseline.
And what you're seeing
within the ecosystem now
is a lot of stuff that's
sitting on top of TensorFlow,
higher level abstractions that
are making it easier and easier
to work with.
And TensorFlow
itself is improving
at an incredible pace.
It actually is able
to run on a number
of different environments
though as well.
It can run on just bare CPUs,
GPUs, or even our own Tensor
Processing Units or TPUs that
are available inside of GCP,
and it can be deployed.
Those models can
be deployed to run
on anything from mobile
devices to large scale VM
infrastructure.
So it really is a very
capable framework,
and there is an incredible
number of blog posts, how-tos,
guides, tutorials out there,
all the way from formal
to informal, of how
to use TensorFlow
for different
classes of problem.
So we've got a good
framework we can build on.
Well now, we need in an
environment to prototype it in,
and that's where, again,
Cloud Datalab comes in.
And think of Datalab as just a
wide open notebook interface,
but we've actually
tweaked the Jupyter
and the IPython
components a little bit
to give you access to
some really simple tools.
So for example,
inside that notebook,
we give you quick
access to running things
like BigQuery queries or looking
at files out of Google Cloud
Storage without having to
import individual libraries
and set those up.
So we try to make it
as easy as possible,
and a first-class citizen
amongst all the other data
services that you
might want to leverage.
But inside those notebooks,
you can explore that data.
You can, obviously, analyze it.
Visualization components
are built right in,
and it's actually perfectly
suited to building machine
learning models.
And it actually plugs directly
into using TensorFlow and even
deploying those models later on.
So here's an example of what
the Cloud Datalab UI looks like,
again, very
notebook-driven, but you
can see we've got a mix of
I'm running some queries.
I'm charting some of the output,
I'm importing some Python
libraries, and I'm actually
writing a function here
for training.
So now, we've got the
first four bits done.
We acquired the data,
we transformed it
into something useful, we were
able to prototype our approach
with a machine learning
framework in an environment,
and we were able to
start building our model.
Now that that's all done, how do
we-- maybe we even trained it,
in that case, in a small,
constrained environment.
But now, how do we train it and
deploy it and run it at scale
and really incorporate
the usage of that model?
So we've got the next step
here is deploying that model
and training and deploying
it and running it at scale.
So for the data
engineer, there's
two main steps
they've got to take.
First thing is they've got to
push that model to the cloud
to train it and then
deploy it, ultimately,
on a running service
that can scale.
And then they've got to
integrate that prediction
mechanism into an application.
So the steps that
we have there are--
or the tools that
we want to use there
are Cloud Machine Learning
Engine and our Cloud APIs
which are basically
just the endpoint you're
going to use here.
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
is an incredibly compelling
product, because it takes
your TensorFlow model,
or it takes your
training task, and it
lets you run it on a much
larger set of infrastructure.
So you can run things like
your TensorFlow models
at an incredible
scale without having
to worry about spinning
up those machines,
configuring them, installing
all the rest of the required
software, coordinating
the work that they do.
TensorFlow is built
to be distributed.
So we can take advantage of
that and create a large cluster
and deploy the job too.
So that it can complete
the training process.
And then when that
training process is done,
you can actually take
that completed model
and push it back
up to the surface.
And say, now, I want to
make this a serving model,
and it gives you
back a URL endpoint
that you can integrate
inside of your applications.
So an example of
what that flow looks
like, for pushing the cloud
and training and deploying,
would be-- you might
want to do some light
preprocessing or heavy,
depending on your input data--
but you're going to preprocess
the data set you've got.
And then, you're going
to submit a training job,
and that training job is a
Python TensorFlow training
task.
You're going to
push that job up,
and there are a series
of parameters that we'll
talk through quickly later on.
But effectively, you're just
giving this job to the service,
and saying, here's
my training task.
I want you to run it across
a number of machines.
Once that job is
done, it will actually
have a little output model.
And you're going
to take that model
and say, now, create an
entry for that serving
model inside of a CMLE,
inside of a Cloud ML engine,
and then you can
create a version.
So you actually have
the ability here now
to take different
models you've created,
attach versions to them,
and maybe even AB test them
as far as like predictions go.
So you have that
capability here.
Once you run that
last command, it's
actually going to
create that URL endpoint
and give you an option
to, again, integrate that
into an application.
So there's two ways
you can actually
test the prediction mechanism,
come in through the top.
We actually have
a test capability
built into the gcloud command,
inside of the gcloud SDK.
So you can just run gcloud
ml-engine predict, tell it
the model you want
to protect against,
give it some input data,
and out pops your answer.
Or you can come
in from the bottom
and iterate into application.
And it really is just a URL
you get to post against.
This is a service
that we host for you
and scale for you as needed.
So that's just an
API you integrate,
and you can post against.
Or you actually have the
option of going a step further
here and saying, I'm going
to wrap this inside of a more
powerful, like Cloud
Endpoints approach,
so I have a good set of
API management capabilities
on top of it.
It's up you.
But ultimately, it's still the
same backend infrastructure,
where both those commands land
you inside of Cloud ML Engine,
and you get those
predictions back out.
So let's put it all
together and figure out
what this looks like.
So you remember, we've got
these six main components--
transforming, understanding,
prototyping the approach,
building the model,
deploying it at scale,
and integrating
with applications.
So when you map
that back to GCP,
you get the appropriate
kind of components here.
So for transforming,
we use Dataprep.
For understanding, we
would use BigQuery.
For prototyping and
maybe building the model,
we might use Cloud Datalab.
When we deploy it,
we're going to deploy it
to Cloud ML Engine.
And finally, we'll use
the API that comes out,
or we can, again, use Cloud
Endpoints to actually integrate
with our running application.
So as part of this, I did want
to walk you through as much
of the UI in real world
as much as possible.
So I'm going to
show, don't tell,
and here's where
the demo should be.
So if we could switch
to the Chromebook.
All right, great.
Can you guys read this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: No.
SANDEEP PARIKH: I'll try to
make it a little bit bigger.
All right, so there's not too
much exciting to show here,
other than this is the
Cloud Storage Bucket,
where I actually dumped the
MovieLens 20 million rating
data set into.
So you can see these are
just the raw CSV files.
They're not terribly exciting
at this part of it, quite yet,
but now we can actually
start Dataprep flow.
So what I did,
inside of Dataprep
is I started a new flow, and
I imported those data sets.
I said, here's where my data
lives inside of Google Cloud
Storage, and now I actually
want to take some action on it.
So the first one was
the Movies data set,
if you remember, and we
executed this cleanup phase.
So I want to switch
to my cleanup tab.
I'm going to show you.
So inside of Dataprep,
as I mentioned earlier,
you can see across the
top that it's actually
sampling all of these
columns and showing me
the distribution of data in
them, which is actually pretty
handy, again, as you're
trying to figure out
what is in these data sets.
And so what you're seeing
right now on screen
is actually the
completed version.
This is a cleansed version.
Well, what if I want to
see the initial version,
before I actually
ran all these steps
that are here on the right.
So I can click on a step, and
now it's actually showing me
the output before that step.
I'm sorry, the version right
after it executed that step.
So you'll see, I've got
things like the movie ID,
the title with the year
still in the title,
and the genres as a
pipe-separate column,
but that pipe separation
is not really helpful.
So I'm actually able to,
here, define a set of steps,
like extract occurrences
of the word from each
of those pipes separated genres.
And then, drop that into a
column, here on the right,
called extract list genres,
and you can now it's an array.
And then, I actually am
able to delete the field
and rename it to genres
to match up what we need.
And then the last step
is I want to extract
the year from that title
and actually make it
a separate column on its own.
So we can see the steps
here, and I'm just
using regular expressions
to pull the year out, drop
the parentheses, and move
that into its own column.
And if I show you this step
in a little bit more depth,
so the first thing I
do is I pick a column.
And then, I have
the option to pick
either some
precanned values here
for searching
inside that column.
Or I can pick a custom pattern,
so I picked a custom pattern
and I said four digits.
I made sure I gave it
some parameters about when
to start and end that regular
expression, and that's it,
and it's off and running.
I was able to add
that to the flow.
Then, I changed the title
that extracted column
into an actual year, and then
I did a little bit cleanup
on the actual individual
movie titles themselves.
So things like removing
quotes, removing
any extra spaces that were
trailing or at the end,
and that's the cleanup step.
So if you go back to the flow
here, so the first thing I did
was I took that raw CSV.
I imported it.
I cleaned up the
file a little bit
to make it a bit easier
to query and use later on,
but I'm not done yet.
I want to add a
couple of fields in.
So I wanted to add
things like the links,
the movie database ID itself,
as well as the IMDB ID.
And I also wanted to have,
inside that movie's data set,
the average rating and
the number of ratings.
So on the ratings
data set, I actually
added this average
ratings by movie,
and you can actually see
the functions that it ran.
I just basically collapse
that rating data set.
And the way it's actually
originally organized,
it's user ID, movie ID,
rating, and a time stamp.
So all I did was I
grouped by user and movie,
and I collapsed it down
into compute the averages
themselves.
And then I was able to join
that back with the movies
data set itself.
So here's what that
join looks like,
and it's a pretty
simple approach.
First thing I did was
I executed a lookup,
if you can see that up there,
against another data set,
in this case links.
So I was able to pull
in the links file,
and then I did another join.
Where I look up the movie
ID against the movie
ID and the ratings data set that
I computed and actually pulled
in the average ratings
and I wanted to.
So now, my data set
looks like movie
ID, average rating,
number of ratings.
I had a total rating
as well, and then
the links, as well as
the titles, the year,
and the genres that we
talked about earlier.
So I've got a pretty far
way through transforming
that data set.
So now, the last
bit we have to do
is, as I mentioned, is
this little arrow up here,
and this actually is the job.
This is where I'm
telling the flow
where do I want to deposit the
result of that transformation.
And so in this
case, I'm actually
going pull in from
that CSV, and I'm
going to replace whatever is in
the MovieLens data set inside
of BigQuery.
So when I run that
job, what happens--
and I'm not going to run
it now, unfortunately,
because it will take
about 30 minutes.
But what's actually
happening behind the scenes
is it's taking those
transformations,
all that all that work
use, all those components
and that recipe,
all those tasks.
And it's packaging them
up as an Apache Beam job
and then pushing that Beam
job to the Dataflow service.
And so the Dataflow service
gets that job and says,
OK well, I might need to
run four or five, six,
who knows how many workers.
I'm going to spin
up those workers.
They'll pull in
the input data set,
and actually execute
those transformations.
So this is something I don't
have to get involved in.
I just run that job,
and I get to walk away.
And then, if I want to see
the results there later on,
I can see that I
ran some of these.
Each of those was
a job outcoming.
So this MovieLens
component, it ran for looks
like it took about 12
minutes to run it through.
The ratings data set
took a little bit longer,
because it's a much
larger file there,
but we've got the
data in BigQuery now.
So now, it's in big BigQuery.
Why don't we go ahead and take
a look at it and do some queries
and see what it looks like.
That might be a
little bit too big,
so I'm going to just
close this on the left.
Inside the BigQuery UI,
inside of the Cloud Console,
you can see things
like query history,
and you save
queries, job history.
If you want to start some
transfers from another service,
you can do those.
We're going to, right now,
focus on just querying
this data set that I've got.
So the MovieLens data
set and I'm looking
at the movies table itself.
I'm just going to close
that, and so we can see here,
inside the UI I'm able
to take a look at things
like the actual fields that
are in this table, some details
around maybe the size.
It's not incredibly large,
about 2.6 megabytes,
and we can also do
a quick preview.
So we actually can
go through this
and again start
exploring the data
and looking at it in a
little bit more depth here.
But looking at it just by
itself is not very exciting.
So why don't we write a query.
So maybe I wanted to
find out, let's say,
what the top rated movies
are for the action genre.
So what I would do
is select, let's say,
movie ID, average rating,
and title and the genres.
So I want those
columns to show up,
and I'm going to do
from MovieLens.movies.
And I would need to filter
now by a specific genre
that I'm looking for.
So I'm actually going
to able to examine
inside each of those
rows, the array field that
holds all those genres, and
actually pull out the I want.
So I'm going to search
for the comedy genre.
So I'm going to use the string
position function say where
inside of the genres of field.
I'm looking for, let's
say, action movies,
and action is greater
than zero, that
means it found the
column there, or found
that entry inside the genre.
And let's say the top 10.
Well actually,
let's first sort it.
So we can say order by number of
ratings and in descending order
and by average rating
in descending order,
and we're going
to get the top 10.
I got a little typo.
Never type live on stage,
because you will always
mistype.
So that's our query,
and one quick thing,
which I love about
the BigQuery UI is
it's hard to read
through this later on.
So you actually have
this nice option
of formatting your
query automatically.
So it makes it a lot
easier to read later on.
Definitely take advantage
of that, if you can.
But now we can run
this, and it's actually
going to run in a
couple of seconds here.
All right.
So now, we've got a list of
the top 10 action movies,
and you can see the genres
in there, on the right side.
We've got the list
of movies here.
None of these are probably
surprising to anyone of you,
but again this is
a sample data set.
But you get the sense
here, we can actually
start querying and
playing with this data.
And we can even do
things like right
from this UI click
Explore in Data Studio,
and it will actually
throws us there
and start giving us some canned
charts we can work against.
But now, we've gone through
the first steps right.
We transformed the data.
We developed a
quick understanding
around it using SQL or
you could use other tools
like Data Studio,
Looker, or Tableau,
or pick your favorite BI tool.
But now, we want to move
on to the next step.
We want to say,
well, let's actually
do some analysis from the
data scientist perspective.
So here's my Cloud
Datalab Python notebook,
and as I mentioned earlier,
inside of those notebooks,
you actually have
this great capability
to run a whole series
of canned commands
around things like running
queries right in line
without actually having to
do the work of importing
the BigQuery SDK and
connecting to a data set
and running a query that way.
We actually give you a lot of
those capabilities just sort
of out of the box to
make it easier over time.
So here I can actually show you,
let's just do a quick little
SQL test of I can run a query
using the % SQL directive,
and I'm going to just select the
top 10 movies that I find back
from the MovieLens data set.
I can execute that
query, and you'll
see that, yes, you'll
note that that was cached.
Because I ran all this
stuff about 30 minutes
before you guys got here to
make sure it still worked.
So now, we can see all
these all the outputs here,
and actually one of
the other things we do,
we give you a couple
different ways to query.
So one is that SQL directive.
Another one is the BQ directive,
and the BQ one is actually
a lot more powerful.
It gives you
different capabilities
inside of the command.
So if I were to write
something like--
let's see.
Let me just add a quick
little code bit here.
I can say % BQ, help, and you
can see there's a whole bunch
of stuff you can do here.
You can take operations
on data sets,
tables, creator execute queries,
do things like sampling.
You can even create user defined
functions JavaScript and run
those.
So you have a lot of work you
can actually create inside
of-- a lot of work you can do
inside of this notebook all
by itself.
But what we're going to do here
is we're just going to say,
let's do a quick aggregation,
a quick group by,
of all the movies in our data
set by their average rating,
just to see what that
distribution looks like.
So the first thing
I do is I'm actually
going to write this query up.
So select average rating is
rating, count star is count,
from movies, and group
by average rating.
And now, I can
actually run that,
and it actually
didn't run the query.
All it did was it saved it
into that variable name,
average ratings count.
And now I can actually
refer back to that later on,
and say, just execute that
previously named query.
So I'll run through
that here and show you.
So that's going to actually
run that average ratings count
query I created, and it shows
you the distribution which
is good.
Now, we can get a
quick view of it.
But what if that's not the best
way to look at this data set?
What if it's easier
to create a chart?
There's actually, it turns
out, there's a chart directive
as well, and I'll show
you a quick bit of that.
Help, so I can say chart, help.
And inside there, you
can see, we actually
support a number of charts
depending on the kind
of data you want to look at.
Whether you want it to be a
candlestick chart or maybe
a timeline or a tree
map or a histogram.
All those capabilities
are baked right
into the console here or
inside of this notebook.
So I'm going to pick columns,
because it's an easy way
to visualize that data set.
So all I have to do
here again is refer back
to that query name
that I used earlier,
that I executed against,
and just tell it
which fields I want to pull
out from the resulting data set
and see that column.
We're in a column view,
and now we can actually
see the distribution.
So this might help
us as we're trying
to figure out how we want
to build our training task.
It doesn't really tie into
the recommendation approach,
but I wanted to
showcase a little bit
the power of Datalab,
because it does
have a lot of capability baked
into this one straightforward
UI.
And then, of course, it is
IPython or Jupyter notebook,
so we have the typical
Python capabilities here.
TensorFlow is actually
already included,
as are things like
NumPy, SK Learn.
So I can say import numpy,
import scikit-learn-- oops--
or I can say import pandas.
So we do as much as we can.
Whoops.
That was my fault. We'll
come back to that one.
We do as much as
we can to make sure
that there is a lot of
the typical libraries
that you want to use baked into
the Datalab core image that's
running here.
But you also have the
ability to import your own
or to add your own.
I'll come back to that one.
Let's say, I wanted to add
something else, something that
wasn't in the image by default.
So there we can actually
run pip commands in line.
So I can put pip install.
Somebody yell out an
elaboration install here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SANDEEP PARIKH: I missed
that say it again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SANDEEP PARIKH: I
couldn't hear you.
Sorry.
So I'll just pick something.
I'm going to pick the
sixth library here,
because it's pretty
straightforward,
actually might
already be in there.
All right, I picked something
that was already there,
but you can see,
running pip commands
is also available to you.
So if you need to install
additional libraries that
are not part of that core
image, you can do that as well.
And then the last bit is
actually writing some Python.
So I'm not going
to run this here,
because there's a whole bunch
more functions that I left out.
But the goal here is
you could actually
create your training task
function right in line here
and actually use some of
those similar directives
to run gcloud commands, to
actually push the training task
function up to the ML Engine
service, to actually run it.
And so I previously
did some of that work,
and let me take a quick look and
show you what that looks like.
So here's an example of
what it looked like for me
to submit the training
job that I had earlier.
So up at the top, I
just defined a handful
of environment variables, where
the input data is where I want
it to dump some of the output.
In this case, this
data was preprocessed,
and I'm using actually a sample
that I'll tell you about in
a minute.
But this sample actually
takes the 20 million
rating and MovieLens
data set, and it trains
a couple of different models.
It does one for a
deep learning model
and another for a matrix
factorization model.
And when you look down
here at this command, what
you're actually seeing is
there's two different sets
of arguments.
The first set, the
first set of arguments
are the actual ones I need to
pass to the ML Engine service.
So things like what is
the actual Python module
name of the task?
In this case, it's trainer.task.
Where is the path
to that package?
It's right in line in the
same directory I'm in.
Where do I want to stage
the intermediate output?
Which region do I
want to run it in?
And what are some of the
configuration parameters
that I want to have there?
We can specify all
those, and then
the second set of arguments
are actually arguments
to my trainer file
itself, to my Python task.
So here, I'm giving it things
like where should I be putting
some of the output data?
What about the evaluation type
or maybe some of the other
features that I'm
trying to expose here?
And then, I'm also doing
the exact same thing
for the factorisation
model further down the way,
and this is submitting
it in async fashion.
So you had that
option with ML Engine.
You could either submit in
synchronous or asynchronous.
If you do it with
sync, it streams
the logs from your
training output
right back to your console.
Or if you do it async, it
gives you back a job ID,
and says, go ahead and
check this job ID later on
to see how it progressed.
Now, if we take a look
at the configuration,
just to show you really quickly,
first thing I do is show you.
So this is one of the input
configuration files we use.
And this configuration
bit is actually
these are arguments you can
specify on the command line
if you want to or not.
But what they're
basically telling
ML Engine is how do you
want me to run your job?
So in this case, the scale
tier I picked-- and there
are different ones, but
effectively, here you
have the option of
saying, I need something
at the most basic level,
so maybe a set of CPUs.
Maybe I want to run on
the, quote, unquote,
"premium level," which is I
think one master and about
10 workers with GPUs.
Or I can run with TPUs as well.
So you have a lot of
flexibility to define
how much you want done here,
how many components you
want to incorporate
into your training set.
And actually, one
thing I didn't mention
that I will mention
here is at the bottom
there you see a section
called Parameters, or params.
And ML Engine offers
this really cool notion
of hypertuning your parameters,
and what that means is you
get to tell us some bounds
on certain parameters.
In this case, I'm going to
talk about learning rate.
There's a Min and Max, and
what I want ML Engine to do
is run multiple
permutations of this
and tell me what's the right
value for learning rate.
So when it finishes this
training, one of the outputs
here is not just the
model, but it's actually
going to tell me
the optimum value I
should use for a learning rate.
So there's a lot
of power just baked
into this mechanism,
where you give it a task,
you tell it which
parameters are flexible,
and that you want to get
the most optimal outcome
for those parameters.
So we could have submitted
that training job,
and when we submit
it, it goes into-- oh,
that's a little too big--
it goes into the
ML Engine UI here.
And I was doing a bunch of
training and breaking things
all over the place.
So here's one example of the
matrix factorization job.
I ran it.
It took about two hours,
because I was only
running it on a single master
with a couple of workers.
And you can see all the
inputs that it gave you,
and the training output
based on the hyperparameters
you gave it.
So now, it's showing me,
for every single run,
every single trial, what the
learning rate it used there
and what the optimal
outcome might have been.
And if you actually were
to look at this in line
when it's running,
you would actually
see a breakdown of every
worker and the CPU usage
for across all
them, the ram usage.
So you get a sense of what's
actually physically happening
behind the scenes, when we're
running those jobs themselves.
But once that
training is completed,
we actually have to deploy
the model to production.
So that's where I'll show
you the final step here.
That's actually in the previous
file that we're showing you.
But it's the component
where I could actually just
run again a series
of gcloud commands,
actually deploy that model to
a production scaling service.
And when you actually run
a couple of those commands,
you get a model in the
model section of the UI.
So in my matrix
factorization model,
I created a default
version, which is v1,
and I now have the
ability to use that model
or set it as default or pick
different versions here.
Again, if you're
thinking about maybe
you have multiple models you
want to serve for a given use
case, maybe for
purposes of AB testing,
different recommendation
approaches.
The version capability is
really nice to have there,
because you can pick and choose
what you want to deploy into.
But now, that's all done.
We've trained our model.
We've got it ready to serve.
We've pushed up to production.
So the last step in
this process is actually
getting a prediction out.
So what I'm going
do here is show you
what that prediction looks like,
really quickly, on the command
line.
So I'm going to need
to do gcloud ML Engine.
I'm going to predict.
I'm going to pick
the model I want.
So in this case, I'm going to
choose the matrix factorization
model.
And then for my input,
you have the option
of supplying either a set
of inputs inside of JSON
and doing an
asynchronous prediction,
or you can actually do a
bunch of batch predictions.
In this case, I'm going to
do a quick synchronous one,
and because this
data was preprocessed
using TensorFlow
records, I'm going
to use a canned TF record that
I had saved off to the side.
Whoops, thanks.
Again, typos, stage,
always happens.
So that's going to
start off and running.
And it needs to be warmed
up again, because I only
ran it an hour ago.
And I have it set to turn off
these things, this production
model, if I'm not using
it very often to save
a little bit of money.
But what it's doing right now is
actually taking that TensorFlow
record input, and
actually it's running it
against the Prediction
API that I've decided upon
and giving me an
actual physical output.
And of course, nothing works
when you run it on stage.
There it goes.
OK.
So I'm not going to tell
you what all this means.
But basically,
because of the way
I structured the input data
into TensorFlow records,
using this approach, it gives
me a set of scores and output
classes for a given user, for
a number of different movies.
So that's a little bit
that end-to-end workflow.
Can we switch back
to the slides?
So I want to plug a
couple of things really
quickly here, because I didn't
do all this work on my own.
There's just not
enough time to come up
with this entire
workflow end to end.
So I definitely leaned heavily
on some of the Cloud ML samples
from the Cloud ML team.
So they were nice enough
to have a bunch of samples
specifically around
this data set that I
chose which was really handy.
But I urge you to
check out that repo,
because nothing beats
actual end-to-end workflow,
and you can read the docs only
so often before you actually
need physical steps to try out.
So these folks have put
together something really useful
that I would definitely
take a look at.
And then the other
thing I leaned on
was a paper that
one of my colleagues
wrote, "Building Recommendation
Systems in TensorFlow."
And he actually goes through
a similar approach, where
he uses MovieLens data set.
But he also goes all
the way to the end,
where he talks about things
like how to actually serve
the model using Cloud Endpoint.
So you have a little bit more
API management on top of it,
where you get more logging,
authorization, and monitoring.
But also talking about
using Cloud Composer,
and how you actually
update models over time,
and how you update
this entire workflow.
Today, for the purposes
of this approach,
I was the one orchestrating
the data landing in GCS,
cleanse with Dataprep,
querying at BigQuery,
and all the way to training
and deploying the model.
But in reality, you're not
to have a person doing that
beyond the first
couple of times,
and that's where Composer
is really your friend.
And it can help you define
that entire workflow
and let you run that
on a regular basis.
Again, as you get
new data in, you
might want to
retrain those models
or deploy them in a
different fashion.
So what does the
typical workflow look
like inside a Google Cloud?
And this is sort of
a superset of what
I've covered here today.
But it really does go
through the steps of--
we have all the tools you
need to go through from data,
to ingest, all the exploration
capabilities, preparing it,
wrangling that data, maybe doing
some level of preprocessing
and then getting into the
machine learning components--
training, hypertuning, testing--
and then deploying those models
either in online predictions
or in batch predictions.
And under the bottom there,
this whole thing lets you--
can be run by Cloud Composer.
It's that orchestration layer.
So that's the bulk of
what I wanted to cover.
Now, where do you go from here?
A couple of things
to think about
as you're looking
into how do you
adopt these sorts of workflows.
So for training, I
definitely recommend
you take a look at GPUs
and maybe even TPUs
to boost your
training approaches.
Because just using bare CPUs,
you could throw a lot of cores
at the problem, but it's not
always the fastest way to go.
GPUs and TPUs are really,
really purpose-built
for linear algebra
in the former case
and specifically
TensorFlow in the latter.
So that could have a
really significant impact
on your training timing.
I like using batch predictions
to fill in historical data.
You're not going to need to fill
in every single request online.
So if you want to fill in
some of the prior work,
you could do that with batch
and that puts a little bit less
strain on relying on
another API to fill data
in when maybe customers are
browsing through your site,
looking for recommendations.
For machine learning,
what's great too is--
and just this week
we have talked more
about using scikit-learn
and XG Boost.
So you don't necessarily
have to use TensorFlow
if you don't want to.
There are other ways
you can get Cloud ML
Engine to host and
serve your models
and do that prediction for you.
And then, the last one we talked
about a little bit as well
was automating the end-to-end
workflow with Composer.
There's actually one other
thing I didn't get a chance
to put on here, which is BQ ML.
It's a really powerful tool.
Again, inside of
that same interface,
where you can query
with standard SQL,
we've added some extensions
to actually do machine
learning right then and there.
So you could do things
like linear regression
right in line, and
it's really powerful.
Again, that might not be the
model used in production,
but every little bit
of work you do along
the way to reduce the amount
the next person has to do,
that has an impact on how long
it takes to get to market.
So what about if you
want to learn more?
So I definitely urge
you to check out
all of the analytics and
machine learning products
that we have inside of GCP.
It's an incredibly
powerful portfolio,
and it just continues
to grow regularly,
especially if you start digging
into where we're investing
around machine learning.
We started, I think,
with the pretrained APIs,
like vision, natural
language, and translation.
And then we went all the way
to the other extreme, and said,
we'll run your TensorFlow
models for you at scale,
and now, you're seeing us invest
a lot more in just the middle.
What if you don't want
to write TensorFlow,
but you want a custom model?
And that's what
Auto ML does for us.
So there's a lot of work
really happening there.
And then I would definitely
have you check out
DA303 later today--
A Modern Data
Pipeline in Action.
Again, it takes this work
that I'm talking about
and gives you a real-world
example from one
of our customers.
As I mentioned, check out
BigQuery ML, really cool.
I think it's a great tool.
And definitely take
advantage of the free trial.
You can do things like store
10 gigs of data for free.
It's out of BigQuery,
and your first terabyte
of processing or query
processing is free every month.
So there's a lot of
wiggle room there
to start playing
around with these tools
and take advantage of them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]